alors j'ai besoin de vous tous vous tous
vous tous même vous à la maison couzier
les meubles cyril j'ai besoin de toi de
toute l'équipe
là on va essayer de se faire un gros
flash mais on va se faire un flash mob
mais pour ça je veux que vous fassiez un
gros bordel pour celui qui va vous
expliquer les steppes de la soirée
monsieur le coach chris s'il vous plaît
faites nous retrouver ok je vais voir si
quelques casquettes
je connais certains c'est le stand amel
bent toujours le point de mai commence à
tout le monde alors on y va et on saute
sur place on y va on saute on saute on
saute
ok stop deuxième step they must est
passé le stade de mohamed ali au niveau
de position comme ça qu'est ce qu'il ya
c'est le short de sopra tension c'est
pas le mien on y va et là aussi basculer
de droite à gauche 5 6 7 8 commence à
épaule à épaule à épaule stop troisième
stade français le step c'est l'accent
circonflexe mais les mac os mais sans
triangle reliant ils sont pas allés à
l'école on y va et on saute on y va au
centre on saute on saute au centre stop
dernier step
le sénat peut préférer le soprano merci
merci je sais attraper le bonheur on
attrape le bonheur à gauche à droite en
disant allez on y va sec puis allez
allez vous écoute
ok nick alors c'est bon je pense que
tout le monde est prêt
[Applaudissements]
attention souffler
[Musique]
allez
[Applaudissements]
à
à l'arrivée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à l'heure
allez j'ai seconde de répit et ans
[Applaudissements]